protesters in ohio are calling for  action  after a 16 year old girl was shot and  killed by police  columbus police released this body  camera footage just  hours after the incident officers there  say 16-year-old makaya  bryant was trying to stab two people  with a knife  and they say that's when an officer  opened fire  deadly force can be used to protect  yourself  or the protection of a third person so  that is within the policy and that was  in the law  that is what the law says whether this  complies with that  will be part of that investigation so  the officer involved is now on  administrative leave that's pretty  normal  critics are calling for justice in  brian's death her mother says she was an  honor  roll student who promoted peace